[Music]
welcome back we're talking about the
Fourier transform and in this lecture
I'm going to tell you about one of my
favorite properties of the Fourier
transform which is how you can simplify
convolution integrals in a spatial
variable by Fourier transforming the
functions F and G okay so the the
convolution of two functions F and G is
defined as F star G and it's given by
this integral here f of X minus C times
G of C with respect to C okay so you
have some dummy variable C you're
integrating with respect to and this X
minus C essentially what that means is
that as C goes from negative infinity to
infinity is that we're sliding our
function G across our function f or
vice-versa and we're adding up their
product as you slide this across from
negative infinity to infinity
so this is a notoriously challenging
integral to compute in practice and so
the Fourier transform is going to
massively simplify this rather
convoluted expression here okay so
that's all I'm going to write and in
particular the way that it simplifies is
as follows so if I have this convolution
F star G and I Fourier transform that
convolution that is equal to just the
regular old product of the Fourier
transform of F times the Fourier
transform of G or if you like you can
just write it as equals F hat G hat okay
so this is really nice if I have two
functions F and G then if I Fourier
transform this convolution it just
becomes a product in the Fourier
transform domain so convolutions become
products through the Fourier transform
that's super useful and in this lecture
I'm going to show you how you can see
that okay this is gonna be a little bit
of heavy math so bear with me all right
nothing too challenging just a lot you
got to keep track of the way I'm gonna
show this is I'm actually going to
inverse Fourier transform F hat G hat
and I'm going to show that you recover
this convolution okay so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna take the
inverse Fourier transform of F hat G hat
and again if I inverse Fourier transform
this I'm going to get
function of space back so I'm just going
to be explicit that this is a function
of X and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
can I'm going to take this inverse
Fourier transform formula for my Fourier
transform pair and I'm gonna plug in F
hat and G hat right here and then I'm
gonna work out what this has to be equal
okay so this would be 1 over 2 pi
integral from negative infinity to
infinity of f hat and this is a function
of Omega G hat of Omega e to the I Omega
X D Omega nothing too difficult so far
I'm just literally plugging this into my
definition of an inverse Fourier
transform and here's what we get ok now
what I'm gonna do is I am going to
replace this G hat with this integral
here I'm actually going to take the
Fourier transform of G and I'm going to
plug in this integral of G of X e to the
minus I Omega X and maybe all yeah maybe
I'll just write that out here so my G of
X is going to become an integral from
negative infinity to infinity that's
this term here of G of and I'm gonna
introduce a dummy variable here this
could be of any function Y G of Y e to
the minus I Omega Y dy because we're
gonna integrate out that dummy variable
so I want to have a dummy variable here
this is really a G of Y e to the minus I
Omega Y D Y that integral is equal to G
hat that's the Fourier transform of G
and I'm just introducing a dummy
variable Y no big deal and then I still
have all of my other stuff I still have
my F hat Omega I still have my e to the
I Omega X DX integral negative infinity
to infinity 1 over 2 pi ok so all I did
here was I took my inverse Fourier
transform of F hat and G hat get this
expression and then for my G hat Omega I
plug in the Fourier transform of G
of some function G of Y in some dummy
variable Y good okay now this is where
it gets it gets a little bit convoluted
but the basic idea is this integral is a
function is an integral with respect to
some dummy variable Y that has
absolutely nothing to do with X or Omega
okay nothing to do sorry this was also a
should be a D Omega here okay so my my
integral in red here has nothing to do
with X and Omega so I can take my F hat
Omega and I can bring it into this
integral and I can take my e to the I
Omega X and I can bring it into this
integral no big deal okay so that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to get my 1
over 2 pi integral negative infinity to
infinity and I'm going to pull this
inside so now I'm going to have another
integral of negative infinity to
infinity F hat Omega G of Y and I'm
going to multiply this e to the I Omega
X times my e to the I minus I Omega Y
and I'm going to get e to the I Omega X
minus y I just multiplied these two
Exponential's and this is kind of
interesting the way I haven't written it
would be dy D Omega but because of kind
of the commutative property of these
integrals I can switch the order of
those and I can write this as d Omega dy
they have the same bounds of integration
I can swap those no big deal so this was
a pretty big step what did we do we
brought our F of Omega and our e to the
I Omega X into this integral because
neither of those vary with Y those are
not functions of Y so I can bring them
inside and then I swapped the order of D
Omega and dy ok that's not too bad but
now this is kind of fun because this
expression here this G of Y this
integral with respect to Y
good okay good good good this G of Y
function is not a function of Omega okay
so I can move this G of Y outside of
this integral okay in fact I'm gonna do
that right now I'm literally just gonna
pull this G of Y outside of this
integral so now I have my G of Y here I
can't pull it outside of the first
integral because that is with respect to
Y and now if you look at this expression
on this inner integral here this whole
expression is the inverse Fourier
transform of F evaluated at X minus y ok
I'm going to let you convince yourself
of this if I take the inverse Fourier
transform of F hat Omega it would be
this expression except instead of an X
here I have an X minus y so instead of f
of X I'm going to get f of X minus y so
this whole thing is going to equal f of
X minus y okay that whole red expression
that's times a G of Y and I'm
integrating this whole thing minus
infinity to infinity with respect to Y
ok so I've recovered my formula for a
convolution in this last step and
there's something I kind of I kind of
messed up here and being a little sloppy
this 1 over 2pi would need to be a part
of this inverse Fourier transform
integral remember this this integral
here has a 1 over 2pi so i'm going to
use this 1 over 2pi when I write this
integral as f of X minus y ok all right
so that's a little bit convoluted that's
not super simple in fact I'm going to
just go through this one more time just
kind of walk you through all of these
steps but the upshot is that if I take
some convolution of F and G when I
Fourier transform that convolution I
just get the products of the individual
Fourier transforms of F and the Fourier
transform
which in my opinion is much much simpler
than doing all of this integral nonsense
the way we saw that was we took this F
hat G hat and we inverse Fourier
transform and we showed that what you
recover is this definition of the
convolution okay so we literally plugged
in f hat and G hat to this definition
here okay we rearrange some of the
integrals we replaced G hat with our
Fourier transform here we rearranged
some integrals we brought in our 1 over
2pi factor here and we find that this
integral with this 1 over 2pi is just f
of X minus y times G of Y and we have an
integral from negative infinity to
infinity so this is literally our
convolution of G with respect to F yeah
that's exactly what this is here and so
this equals equals F star G ok so the
inverse Fourier transform of F hat G hat
is equal to F star G which means that if
I Fourier transform this I would get F
hat times G hat okay this is really
really useful but we're gonna find in
lots of partial differential equations
like the heat equation the solution of
the heat equation is going to involve
some convolution integral of maybe my
initial condition with a Gaussian
diffusion kernel and it's going to be a
lot easier to compute that by Fourier
transforming those functions my
diffusion current on my gouge and
diffusion kernel and my initial
conditions so it's gonna be a lot easier
to work in the Fourier transform domain
for things like the heat equation where
we have the solution easily represented
as a convolution integral are naturally
represented as a convolution integral ok
thank you